-You have a story.
You go to see an endric--
-Endocrinologist.
-What is that?
-I do.
Well, that's somebody -- I have
this thing called hypothyroid,
which is I think common with
some women.
But basically I love my
endocrinologist.
And I have this thing
called ASMR.
It's like some type of
neurological response
to soft voices and really --
And there's ASMR videos
on YouTube where people go,
"Hi. I'm going to
start the session,"
and they talk into microphones,
but that doesn't trigger me.
I have to have real people
who have soft voices.
And when they have a soft voice,
you get triggered into,
like, a full --
you feel like you're getting
a full body massage.
Like, you feel so relaxed.
-Oh, that's fantastic.
-Yes.
-So this is kind of a nice thing
to have.
-This is so nice.
So I kind of make appointments
with him, just to see him,
because I love the sound of
his voice.
I'll be like, "Dr. Cohen,
I just wanted to check
my blood levels for my thyroid."
And then he's like "Molly, the
blood levels look very good."
He's very calm.
I'm not doing a good imitation.
He's so calm,
and so he's just like,
"I think the blood
looks very good."
I'm like,
"Do I have Hashimoto's?"
And he's like --
This story's going nowhere.
-I have a follow-up question.
-Is he aware of what his voice
is doing to you?
-I did. I told him, I go,
"Dr. Cohen, I love your voice."
I go, "It's so calm."
And he was like, "Thank you."
He goes, "I actually did
an emergency procedure
where we had with other doctors
practicing during
a high-emergency situation
and they all said
that I was too calm."
And I was like, "Yes, you are."
Yeah, so he just has
such a soft voice.
-That's great.
But you also, you actually got
an actual physical massage?
-Oh, yes.
-That maybe crossed the line.
-Yes.
I was in Ojai, and I had a woman
masseuse, and she was very --
She didn't speak English
that well, but she was like,
"Oh, you know,
take off the panties."
I was like, "Oh, okay.
European style."
I was like, "Okay."
'Cause, you know.
So she's like massaging,
massaging, massaging.
And then oils,
I was like, "Ooh, so oily."
-You know, and then she's, like,
really kind of going down
toward my butt.
I was like, "Whoo."
And then, like, more oils
and really scooping down.
-Wow.
-I was like really getting damp.
More oils, and I was like,
"Oh, my God.
Is she --
Am I being violated?"
I was like,
"I think I'm being violated,
but this feels so [bleep] good!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Is it safe to say that
had your endocrinologist been
there at the same time talking,
you would have just exploded?
-Exactly. Literally.
-Thanks so much for being here,
Molly.
Always a pleasure seeing you.
Molly Shannon, everybody.